i think it's you know it's scary at
times because you uh you really are
you know potentially uh influencing the
way hundreds of millions
of people think a month
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me how are
you how are you good how are you
wonderful hey where are you calling from
right now oh i'm in palo alto
you're in palo alto and i have to
congratulate you
on a pretty big transition right after
many years at
cora also quite a few years really four
years of vp of product
you've recently your your service there
and you're and you're on to some
different things and and i'd love to
chat about your experience with cora and
some of the really interesting things
that you've done both that are
mainstream today but also that weren't
necessarily mainstream back when you
were working on them
and but i'd like to start all the way
back and going back to stanford you're
you're doing your phd over there in
economics and you're working on some
really interesting things that
that i just love both matching theory
and political economy
tell me a little bit about yourself and
what led you to do that research
at stanford yeah a great question
um so i'm uh you know i've been curious
about economics for for years kind of
before coming to stanford i was
doing uh my ba and masters at the hebrew
u
in jerusalem and was mixing math and
econ
throughout and i was really interested
in this
kind of intersection where the theory
and kind of the beauty of mathematics
can be applied to real world problems
maybe like the epidemic of that is
as auction theory which won the nobel
prize a few weeks ago
motivating uh kind of energy coming in
and a chance to be in quite a few
lectures by milgram
uh this past year and i i have to say
that i didn't understand much
but but it was still fascinating
nevertheless
yeah i was in a reading group with with
him uh for kind of a couple years it was
really fascinating to kind of see him
like think and kind of uh you know
appreciate his his point of view on the
world it's it's quite it's extraordinary
so yeah so you can talk about your
research yeah yeah
um anyway so i i got curious uh you know
what else
what other kind of beautiful mathematic
applications can be used to
understand the world or maybe improve
the world uh
and kind of matching markets was a
really fascinating thing it was
kind of blowing up and within economics
at the time people were
innovating on matching theory to do
things like kidney donations and
matching kids to schools in a really
efficient way
and some of those uh kind of techniques
were actually implemented then
in the you know kidney donation market
uh or in actual school systems like in
boston and new york
which were changing how they were
running things using uh economic theory
and with like you know broad
economists as kind of the the people
planning these systems
so that that was kind of how i got
pulled into this uh like area
so i have to spend some time talking
about the beauty of mathematics
and you know and enlighten both myself
and
and a lot of my my viewers that aren't
necessarily you know leaning into the
mathematical world i am but i know a lot
of my friends who are excited about
innovation aren't leaning there how
how does mathematics play a role into
our lives whether it's matching theory
or political economy i'd love to really
understand this world a little bit
better and and show some of the
excitement
yeah so for me a lot of it comes from uh
and
i think this is kind of the modern way
to view economics is from incentives so
if you can
uh describe with a little bit of math it
doesn't need to be
super sophisticated what people's
preferences are
and what kind of outcomes they prefer uh
then you can uh you know model the world
again with fairly simple
primitives and and use uh
this description of incentives to
predict behavior and if you can predict
behavior
then you can go one step uh higher and
describe what kind of systems would
actually
push for better behavior on the part of
the economic agent
so in the case of let's say school
choice
if people have you know preferences over
schools and they they want to be matched
with
uh a specific school for their kid and
that may involve many
uh different types of considerations
like what are your you know the other
kids in the family are they going
already to schools in the in the system
uh what kind of focus areas does that
school have and you know what is that a
good match for their child or not
how close is the school to where they
live and kind of model all of that out
and again this is not you know rocket
science is
kind of fairly simple uh uh ways of
creating kind of lists of preferences
uh then you can think of okay if i ask
people and have
incentives that are aligned in the sense
that the system will
actually respect your preferences and
give you the best outcome for the
preference as you you stated uh then you
can think of designing these systems in
a way where
matching is quote unquote optimal and
you can get the the best outcomes for
the most like the largest amount of
people
so that's you know for me a really neat
thing where you can take mathematical
models
uh and kind of solve them in a way which
uh generate better icons for people
you know on in in their real lives on
the things that matter most of them
a hundred percent i'd have to say that
i've i've been getting exposed to the
process of of
residency and and doctors people the
people in medical school
that are getting there and and you know
on one hand it seems yes matching is a
problem it's a little bit longer
sometimes it's not ideal but then when
you meet
the person that's actually going through
that process and this is not a
life-threatening situation right
like kidney donations or stuff like that
but you can still see the impact of
what mathematics and algorithms can do
to help ease the process
let alone save lives that is that is
beautiful as you mentioned that is
beautiful mathematics and i'm extremely
excited to continue my studies and get
and get to those levels and then what
about the political economy how does
math play into
uh you know politics and what's yeah i
got pulled into it through my wife who
was also doing a phd at stanford at the
same time and she was uh in the
political science department
but actually had a very similar
background from kind of a game theory
and
mathematics perspective um and we were
both kind of curious this is this is
like again a really good timing because
we were doing this uh kind of pre-arab
spring but we got really curious on this
topic of protest
especially protests in authoritarian
regimes so these are people who are
taking a big chance and risking their
lives and going to
voice you know their concerns or their
objections to the regime under the
threat of you know arrest
or execution and kind of why are they
doing that what kind of dynamics
contribute
to them taking that chance what are they
looking to get out of it
uh and so we were using a kind of a
mixed approach of both looking at
empirical data but also building a
mathematical model
that would try to explain under what
conditions would people actually take
that chance and again take on
meaningful costs uh to to get an outcome
and that that outcome is political
and so kind of uh reached uh a model
where you know the economic conditions
were often
a strong determinant of when protests
might happen
and what's the probability of that
process actually having an impact
uh and again the timing was really
opportune because we were doing this
just before the kind of arab spring
where we saw this actually play out
with you know many many regimes being
toppled or at least
shaken by mass protest movements
something that wasn't
seen for basically decades so when we
were originally taking on this research
it was kind of out of
like vogue to to study protests because
it was like this never happens or this
isn't
meaningful and then we a year or two
later we saw this unfold so it's really
a kind of a fun experience to to be
thinking about these problems
so yeah you're working on these
mathematical models
you're thinking about about about all
about all this and
all of a sudden the arab spring springs
happens and and you're watching this and
and i have to get into the into the
perspective that you're at
i believe it's like 2010 2011 2011 right
how how does this all play out are you
surprised are you
do are you anticipating does this does
this research take on a greater role
what happens there yeah so
uh we definitely were surprised again
this was not something that we we
had seen since probably you know the
fall of the soviet union where
people work on muppling regimes uh by
going out into the streets
uh so so it was a shock i mean it was is
kind of
you know very relevant or like eerily
similar to what the dynamics we
described in in our papers
because uh ultimately the logic was kind
of very simple if things get kind of bad
enough from an economic perspective
or people are desperate enough they'll
take that that chance that was like the
the heart of the model
uh but really connecting it to like the
um the empirics and actually kind of
being able to predict this was was the
neat part of the research
uh and so it was it was both surprising
but very kind of consistent in the in
the same
uh at the same time and i kind of
both my wife and i were in the process
of kind of leaving academia but for
uh the professor we were working with uh
in the political science department this
was
a very good boost for her career
unbelievable
and so you're at at that point you're
living academia
and you have a series of different
experiences throughout your professional
career
leading up to your up to your job at
core now i know quora
as this beautiful website that i go to
to answer
all of the relevant and irrelevant
questions that i may have
uh but but walk me through a little bit
your your life path
that led to being vp of product at such
an awesome company yeah
so i i it can it may seem random but i
think there is a thread connecting
everything
or at least i'd like to believe so uh so
for me kind of what
uh i've enjoyed or what i've been
attracted to is how do we kind of
again use kind of math or uh you know
logic to unlock a lot of value
and that that's something that's kind of
always driven me or i was i've been
passionate about
and with quora as an economist this is
actually a fascinating
thing to dive into because uh you can
think about quora
um and i think this is true of knowledge
more more generally as
a market there there are people who need
certain answers to certain questions
those may be
very important or trivial that's all
fine
and there are other people in the world
who who know the answers to those
and kind of how do you connect the two
sides of this market
uh and how do you unlock value and how
do you create the right incentives for
people
uh to be kind of sharing that online and
in a public way
that was like the the key question that
that motivated me and actually my first
project
uh that i got put on was we had a
concept at the time that we later
kind of deprecated called core credits
which was a way for people
uh to accumulate kind of virtual money
this is kind of pre-bitcoin bringing
you know that everything about virtual
money um
so accumulate this this kind of uh point
system
and be able to spend it by uh asking
the people directly for their question
for their answers on a question
so you you basically got a an ability to
kind of
uh buy some someone's attention by
sending them a notification and an email
saying hey can you answer this question
and and so each person had kind of a
dynamic price
of you know how much is their attention
worth and that was based on supply and
demand
dynamics in the marketplace and uh
again if you were a good member of the
community and you had supplied value
yourself
then you were able to kind of utilize
that and kind of get value or get
knowledge out of somebody else's head
that was like a kind of a beautiful
concept to me and something that really
pulled me into working for for the
company
wow so you know a marketplace of
knowledge
in an age of misinformation and you know
you
your vp of product i believe all the way
back from 2016 right you're seeing
what what is happening with the election
and then and you know when i look on
on social media and and and those sorts
of those sorts of areas
i it's very hard for me not to be
pessimistic about about where we're
headed with
with misinformation and and i it's
almost like a promise to myself that
i'll
only really accept knowledge when i see
it
you know cross-sectioning from various
sources and i take pride in that but how
do you as vp of product
approach this you know mentality that we
have a real issue on our hands and it's
growing exponentially right
i mean it's getting out of control yeah
uh this is a great question and i think
for us like
we were actually very uh kind of in some
sense
validated by all this happening that
this is kind of sounds ironic
but we have we at that point had been
worried about you know
kind of misinformation or just generally
what's true or not for many years
for us you know under like our mission
is to share and grow the world's
knowledge and
by that we mean real knowledge that is
useful to people uh misinformation
something that undermines
as you were saying people's trust and
knowledge so for us it was a
existential threat if you know the
platform can be manipulated
uh into you know showing or prominently
or spreading
uh information that's not actually true
that undermines trust in the
in the platform that reduces the
incentives for people to suffer for
knowledge and because of these
marketplace dynamics
i was describing it also reduces the
incentives of you know good people to
actually share
the the right information because
there's all this other junk
out there that might drown out uh you
know what they are saying or what they
are sharing
so for us we were thinking about this
problem uh kind of years earlier one of
kind of the
uh key moments for me and that journey
was uh we had a digest email or still
have it i just seen this was one of more
popular kind of um kind of emails out
there that go out and to you know
hundreds of millions of people
and has personalized information for
them something we had invested a lot in
and there was uh i believe this was in
2014 or 2015 we had sent
out uh to were collecting hundreds of
thousands or a few million people
an answer at the top of their email that
had basically kind of a 911 conspiracy
theory content in it
like featured prominently and that was
like a real wake-up moment of hey if
we're
approaching this purely algorithmically
with you know all these algorithms that
uh you know try to understand what
people like but we do this on the base
of fairly kind of
shallow signals like clicks and you know
uploads we may fall into these traps
and we really have to put in some
guardrails and make sure that we don't
let
that kind of uh you know quote-unquote
information to take over
and so we had been thinking about this
for years before the election
and for us kind of seeing the rest of
the industry suddenly realizing hey
there's a massive kind of problem here
and we should start kind of you know
being a lot more careful
about you know free speech quote unquote
uh was
was again validating in some sense
because we had been working on this for
for years
wow that's a lot of responsibility isn't
it
to sit in that chair and understand that
the things that you're working on are
the
core of information absolutely i mean i
think it's you know it's scary at times
because you
uh you really are you know potentially
uh influencing the way hundreds of
millions
of people think a month and you know
that those
uh you know subtle nudges towards you
know believing things aren't true
are risky from a political perspective
you know if social stability perspective
uh you know medical advice like all
these areas are are
hyper important to people's lives and if
you're uh you know pushing the wrong
stuff out there
that is uh that is you know the opposite
of our mission that is that is dangerous
and so uh that that's kind of a fear or
a concern
uh again we were like occupied for
with for a long time um and it's just to
call out and be kind of a little um
charitable to
other platforms it's a really kind of
tricky area you don't wanna it's very
hard to
uh be the voice of kind of truth and be
an arbiter of hey
every little fact you know we're talking
about millions and millions of answers a
week
uh what's like what's true or not nobody
can kind of sift through that and make a
decision you even saw this with the
pandemic or the early information that
you know the most credible agencies were
pushing out was actually false
and at that time it was very hard to
kind of again make that call so
you need to strike this balance of
allowing debate and allowing uh you know
enough spectrum of views
uh to kind of have its you know fight
out there and kind of
have that evolution of ideas but at the
same time the stuff that's kind of
intentionally false or deliberately
misleading or it's kind of the
conspiracy theory realm
have a really hard line there and have
the mechanisms in place where you can
squash that when it arises
so it's really unfair that i'm asking
you this when we have uh
literally a minute and a half to the
interview but where are we headed what
needs to happen
so that you know when i watch as i watch
my niece who is six years old
as she grows up and she gets more into
social media and she's
so curious how how can i help her how
can the world help her
gain curiosity in the right way yeah i
think that's a really key question and i
think that you know this
is a really interesting interesting
intersection of regulation
uh kind of corporate responsibility on
the side of platforms
uh and frankly a lot more i think debate
that needs to happen there so i
i don't have like a magic bullet but i
do think platforms needs to spend
a lot more thought and time about uh
kind of striking that
balance and making sure their algorithms
don't
kind of trend or have these feedback
loops that end up in these you know
places where people become convinced of
flat air theories
for real because of like some rabbit
hole they went down through
in youtube so i i honestly think that
you know the right
solution is some regulation potentially
not a massive amount
but a lot more kind of corporate effort
uh to
kind of squash these these pockets of
the internet that are really dangerous
and we've obviously seen the the
sensitivity behind this
the the the intersection between
regulation and and private companies and
what's happening especially as we've
seen in the most recent election
some of twitter's actions some of
facebook's actions that you know even a
single action
could like like flagging a comment by a
an official in the white house as
something that may be not correct
that stirs up some very meaningful
conversations about debate the
foundation of
of what is the responsibility of these
private companies
as well as what is the responsibility
for for their own company but also for
the citizens and for the integrity
of a free and fair election or democracy
uh
yeah i want to thank you for being so
kind with your time it's so generous
i could go on this for another two hours
because everything that we've touched
here
is so fascinating and so remarkable
so thank you for sharing that with me
before we leave i have to ask you for
three words
that you would use to describe yourself
optimistic persistent
and curious
so after all of that optimistic
persistent and curious
i just love it thank you so much here
this was just wonderful tadaba
thank you so much